ahora que ya vimos varios ejemplos
acerca de la regla de la cadena es el
momento perfecto para entender la teoría
que hay detrás entonces a esta vez vamos
a ver de dónde sale y cómo funciona en
general la regla de la cadena supongamos
que fx es una composición de funciones
alguna vez cuando estábamos viendo
álgebra de funciones vimos la
composición de funciones entonces fx va
a ser h de otra función hdr de x una
composición de funciones o dicho de otra
manera la función h tiene como variables
a una función a la función que bueno
ahora la pregunta es quién es la
derivada de la composición de funciones
lo primero que hay que hacer es sacar la
derivada de la función de adentro es
decir derivamos a g y obtenemos que
prima de x ya está hay que multiplicarla
por h prima pero no de x va a ser h
prima de g de x
muy bien entonces ya tengo aquí mi regla
de la cadena como una fórmula en general
ahora sí ya tenemos la definición de la
regla de la cadena por lo tanto pues
vamos a ocupar la pero esta vez voy a
ver ejemplos distintos a la vez pasada
bueno esto que voy a empezar es muy
parecido al de la vez pasada pero vamos
a concretar cosas me voy a tomar a fx
como x cuadrada más 5 x + 3
todo esto elevado a la quinta potencia
den se cuenta que la función x cuadrada
más 5 x + 3
toda esta función está elevada a la
quinta potencia por lo tanto x cuadrada
más 5 x + 3 va a ser mi candidata a
hacer la función g entonces voy a llamar
a g de x x cuadrada más 5 x más 3 esta
va a ser mi función g y a esta función
la voy a componer con otra ahora bien y
otra función con la que voy a componer a
g va a ser h quien va a ser mi propuesta
para h pues de se cuenta que tenemos a x
45 x más 3 elevado a las 5 entonces con
esta idea
qué hdx es x elevado a la quinta
potencia muy bien y seguramente ustedes
van a decir oye sal pero porque hdx es
igual a equis a la quinta potencia hay
algo raro aquí pero es que no se han
dado cuenta que cuando nosotros
componemos a hdx con de x obtenemos a
efe x es decir hdx compuesta de x es lo
mismo que x cuadrada más 53 todo esto
elevado a las 5 o dicho de otra manera
esto es fx y bueno ya que tenemos todo
en orden es hora de aplicar la regla de
la cadena entonces qué nos dice la regla
de la cadena pues primero dice f prima
de x es igual a g prima de x entonces
voy a necesitar derivada g
hagamos una vez pero como no estoy
quedado sin espacio voy a hacer una
pequeña línea por aquí y voy a poner por
acá la derivada de g de x es decir que
prima de x y quieres que prima de x pues
bueno es 2 x más 5 la derivada de x
cuadrada es 2 x la derivada de 5x es 5 y
la derivada de 3 pues
aparece la derivada de una constante 0
muy bien y ahora voy a apuntar también
la derivada de hd x es decir h prima de
xy 15 h prima de x pues es una regla del
exponente 5x elevado a la cuarta la
derivada de x elevada a la quinta es
igual a 5 x 4 muy bien entonces ahora sí
sí ya tengo yo efe de x por lo tanto
puedo poner su derivada y la voy a poner
hasta acá para confundirte lo más
óptimamente posible no no es cierto
bueno ahora sí sustituyamos a efe prima
de x primero me dice f prima de x es
igual a prima de x entonces voy a poner
que prima de x es decir la derivada de g
muy bien y después a esto hay que
multiplicarlo por h prima deje de x es
muy importante eso no es h prima de x es
h prima de g de x es decir cada vez que
yo vea axn h prima voy a poner completa
a g entonces que sería h prima deje de x
pues sería 5 veces y en lugar de x voy a
poner a todo que cinco veces gx elevado
a la cuarta
ahora si sigues todo esto pues lo voy a
sustituir aquí 5 veces x cuadrada + 5 x
todo esto elevado a la cuarta y bueno
creo que hasta aquí he logrado
confundirte lo suficiente así que
entonces seré un par de ejemplos más y
voy a borrar todo el pizarrón bien
hagamos otro ejemplo y me voy a tomar
ahora una función un poco más difícil
pero por lo pronto vamos a hacer un
recordatorio de lo que tenemos nosotros
sabemos que fx es una composición de
funciones de hecho para eso sirve la
regla de la cadena entonces fx es hd g
de x muy bien si fx está escrita así
entonces la derivada de x por la regla
de la cadena es g prima de x x h prima
de g de x
muy bien entonces ya tengo aquí mi regla
de la cadena y vamos a ver el siguiente
ejemplo voy a decir que en esta ocasión
gx gx que le voy a tomar de azul va a
ser igual a que funciona y voy a decir
que es x elevado a la potencia 7 ya esto
le voy a restar 3 veces x elevado a la
menos 3 muy bien y ahora me voy a tomar
con rojo a hdx quien va a ser hdx en
esta ocasión ok entonces llamar ea hd x
lo sé voy a hacer una función que su
derivada sea muy directa una función
rápida de analizar voy a tomarme x pero
elevado a una potencia difícil elevado a
la menos 10 muy bien ya tengo a gd x ya
tengo a hdx x detractor ya tengo a efe x
porque quieras f x fx es h deje de x
entonces hagamos de una vez h
aquí voy a poner adentro hdx pero quede
x estaba con color azul y dejé x quienes
recordamos como hacíamos una composición
de funciones
yo voy a tomar a hdx y cada vez que vea
x voy a poner completita gmt por lo
tanto va a ser x a las 7 menos 3 x a la
menos 3 en paréntesis y todo esto lo voy
a elevar a la potencia menos 10 es decir
agarre hdx y cada vez que llovía x puse
a g y esto es f x por lo tanto es pero
hasta aquí ya tenerlos bastante
confundidos para que ustedes me llamen
tal vez tengan que ver los vídeos un par
de veces más pero seguramente si los ven
y hacen un poco de análisis van a
entender lo que está sucediendo bueno si
ya tengo a fx ahora ya puedo calcular el
fin prima de x que quien va a ser dice
primero deriva a gd x entonces voy a
agarrar ag de x y la voy a derivar pero
es una derivada sencilla es la derivada
de g es un poco fácil de hacer entonces
hagamos la es 7 veces x a las 6 bajamos
el exponente
bajamos el exponente menos por menos más
3 por 39 y menos 3 al menos 1 es menos 4
entonces es 7x a la 69 x a la menos 4
muy bien y después dice ahora x
h prima de gx entonces primero
calculemos la derivada de hdx y la
derivada de hdx es menos 10 bajamos el
exponente y después ponemos a equis y le
restamos 1 el exponente menos 10 menos
unos menos 11 muy bien si ya tengo la
derivada de hd x ojo estoy tomando la
derivada primero de hdx y aquí voy a
poner la derivada de h dg de x entonces
va a ser menos 10 que multiplica a algo
elevado de menos 11 pero quién va a ser
ese algo ese algo por mi fórmula de la
regla de la cadena es gd x entonces le
voy a poner x a las 7 menos 3 x menos 3
y que acabe ya tengo por fin la derivada
de f
ya tengo f prima de x espero no
seguirlos confundiendo mucho pero no
está tan difícil es ponemos la derivada
de la función interior y después
derivamos la función exterior y ponemos
adentro de la esta derivada a la función
interior muy bien voy a hacer otro
ejemplo muy rápido para que vean que no
es necesario siempre hacer todo esto de
fx gdx hdx voy a hacerlo de una manera
más rápida me voy a tomar a fx esta vez
a 5 veces x no menos x a la 8 y a esto
le voy a sumar x a la menos 8 y todo
esto lo voy a elevar a la quinta
potencia muy bien entonces quién va a
ser la derivada de f de x es decir f
prima de x pues bueno primero hay que
derivar lo que está dentro entonces la
derivada de la función interna es menos
8x a la 7 esto estaba fácil y después es
menos 8 x a la menos 8 menos uno que es
menos 9 muy bien y después hay que
multiplicarlo por 5 por 5 se puede
multiplicar entonces
5 x 5 25 paréntesis algo paréntesis
elevado a las cinco menos uno o sea
cuatro muy bien pero qué es lo que voy a
poner adentro de este paréntesis pues
voy a poner a la función interna tal
cual es decir menos x a la 8 más x a la
menos ocho y ya está es así de fácil
esto se puede simplificar un poco pero
ya logramos derivar de una manera mucho
más rápida por la regla de la cadena así
que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo